big thank you to Omni Heroes for
sponsoring today's video Hajime no EO
you might have heard of it this
legendary Sports manga penned by the
equally legendary joji morawa follows
the life and career of the titular IO
munachi who takes up boxing in the hopes
of answering the burning question what
does it mean to be strong it started
serialization on October 11th 1989 has
sold over 100 million copies and uh
that's about it everything I know about
this story because despite its worldwide
popularity and critical Acclaim Hajime
no EPO hasn't been officially released
in English this might not make sense to
some of you but to me it's important
that I review stories that are available
to be supported simply because I truly
believe in fair use and in order to
avoid being a hypocrite that means I
have to stick to fair use principles
when they both suit me and when they
don't I've wanted to cover this story
for years but it wasn't n available in
English so I never covered it until
today right now you can read hajim noo
through K manga kodansha's website they
have taken it upon themselves to be the
first organization to officially
localize this world famous manga for all
of us English speakers currently only 87
chapters of the story have been
officially localized for us so it's up
to you guys to show this series the
support it needs to reach the Finish
Line oh and uh did I mention that as of
writing this video Hajime noo has over
1,400 chapters to its name for years now
the longest manga I've ever reviewed on
this channel has been one piece by a
wide margin but when you compare these
two stories well let's just say in terms
of length it's it's not even close I'm
thrilled to finally say that I Mark
Fitzpatrick today will be sharing my
first impressions of thoughts on and
blind review for the inspirational
Relentless and legendary story of hajim
no
[Music]
EO how you may know EPO is a Titan of a
manga not just in its length as it's
obvious but in terms of the requisite
analysis one needs to implement in order
to effectively break it down normally
the fashion with which I write these
video essay reviews is by reading
sections one piece at a time taking
notes as I go and concluding on a
predetermined chapter after which I
unpack and make sense of my time reading
resulting in a script that's partially
analysis partially semi live reaction
and commentary this did not work for
hajim noo why well because I had too
much to say and it was boring so instead
I've taken a new approach as I write
what you are hearing right now I have
read every single chapter officially
available to us as English speakers and
moreover everything I will be covering
in this video has already been read by
me and now armed with that knowledge I
want to once again attempt to explain my
complicated feelings concerning Hajime
noo because while in some ways it's
exactly what I had hoped for in other
ways it's remarkably different
introduction no EPO as a reviewer when I
consume a new piece of media one of the
most exciting sections of the story to
cover has been the introduction how a
story establishes itself can tell you
not only a lot about the world and cast
but can also tell you where this story
might ultimately be going and how it
will go there this is why when it comes
to stories like one piece in Naruto I
spent a lot of time looking at the
characterization of Luffy and Naruto
themselves as the story unfolded
alongside the authors that wrote them
and hajo IO was a roller coaster The
Story begins with articular character IO
as we see him go about his unfulfilling
day-to-day life he's a kind-hearted shy
and meek student that diligently helps
out with his widowed mother's fishing
business and gets beaten up on the
regular by The Usual Suspects it's
during one of those routine beatdowns
that a jogging boxer by the name of
takamura stumbles upon this lopsided
confrontation to make the save on the
young EO and from here it's pretty
straightforward to see what happens EO
thanks takamura and seeks out what he
knows takamura offers him a chance to
prove himself by catching leaves that
fall from a tree and then introduces him
to the gym he trains at it's a tail as
old as time this however is the very
first time I've ever read a sports manga
and more than that it's the very first
time I've ever read a boxing Centric
comic I've been a massive fan of boxing
all of my life both keeping up with it
alongside my father in real life
watching films inspired by it and even
dabbling in a handful of classes here
and there myself I've got great respect
for the sport both from a competitive
and storytelling standpoint you need
look no further than the Rocky and Creed
films to see how well positioned this
sport is to tell captivating and human
stories and needless to say these were
the expectations I had coming into this
series however as I learned nothing
about hajim no EO played out how I
expected it to and while there are still
many big events still to come for EO in
the story I want to take a moment to
talk about a very exciting event coming
up with the sponsor of today's video
Omni Heroes if you're somehow not aware
this game is an immensely popular
strategy RPG that's currently taking the
Google Play and App Store B storm
players are tasked with rescuing a
series of captive Valkyries from the
demons at large and to do so well you're
going to be summoning all kinds of
insanely well-designed Heroes putting
these teams together unlocks synergies
that provides crazy awesome Buffs to
your party it's simple enough on the
surface for anyone who wants to kick
back and unwind but if you want some
meaty depth just know that this game has
over 100 team comps you can also earn
rewards passively thanks to the
automated mechanics system so if you
ever need a break just kick back and the
rewards will come straight to you heck
you can even use the quick battle option
to skip over fights to earn rewards even
faster there are just so many different
ways to play based on what suits you
best on November 17th Omni Heroes is
hosting its Ashen Phantom event that not
only drops in sick new story but also
delivers brand new Rog likee dungeon
gameplay now is a great time to dive in
and if you use my link in the
description you can claim
777 free summons and five Legendary
Heroes all within the first week once
again the link is in the description and
I hope you have
fun as I outlined the beginning of hajo
IO follows a very familiar structure
akin to many Coming of Age combat
Centric films of the ' 80s and '90s
however despite laying the groundwork
for a dramatic or emotional story what
with a friendless kid with a struggling
mother being our main character hajo IO
didn't take the route I thought it would
where one piece focused on establishing
and bonding us to the character of Luffy
hajo IO doesn't spend as much time
bonding us to the young EO necessarily
instead and to my surprise a tremendous
amount of time is spent familiarizing
the audience with the real star of this
series box back I'm back I'm back I'm
back I'm back to the truth be told I
feel on fire when my passion FL I'm back
to I'm back to I'm back to I'm back
I'm back to let the truth be I feel when
my passion
flows to the uninitiated boxing can at
times appear mindlessly violent and well
sort of boring with two buff individuals
exchanging near misses holding each
other against the ropes grunting
exhaustively depending on the fight it
can be a hard cell but like any
complicated video game without first
understanding the rules personalities or
strategies involved it can be a SLO to
sit through as any newbie watching the
likes of Starcraft or valerin might tell
you and this is why more traditional
battle Shonen stories typically leave
the martial arts rather vague utilizing
more simplistic Power Systems that in
turn offer up a more traditional and
flexible means of injecting complexity
into these fights whether that be Dragon
Ball's Kei one piece's devil fruit
Naruto's Jutsu Hunter Hunter's nen or
any other popular and thoughtfully
designed power system the benefits are
there for all of us to see quite clearly
hajim noo has no such power system where
other Shonen stories utilize elements
and philosophies from the martial arts
that have inspired them I don't think
I've ever come across a fighting Centric
Shonen so Faithfully representing the
sport it's taken inspiration from and as
a quick aside coming from a guy who's
really into Dragon Ball I am utterly
Bamboozled by just how much this manga
and Mori Caba the author understands not
just boxing but the extremely fine
details of the sport details that come
into Focus the moment that we and EO
walk into takamura's boxing gym details
that become exposed the moment IO is
tested with a Spire to prove himself
against this Gym's promising New
Prospect Miata thus far in this story
all we've seen is unorthodox training
offered up by takamura to EO manifesting
in him just punching at some leaves and
despite this being the first eventual
bout we get to see fromo it is
absolutely not the last we'll see or
even a rare occurrence contained in the
material I'm covering today is a long
laundry list of fights each one better
than the last climaxing at an event I
won't touch on yet because we've got
this fight to contend with first and
what's more is we need to understand how
boxing works first and
foremost EO versus
Miata EO versus Miata and the rivalry
that's established here is the mechanism
with which carries us through the story
for the most part it's a story that's
told through a sequence of fights
climaxing at one pivotal moment in time
and it all begins
here one of the multitude of reasons I
enjoy analyzing the beginnings of and
introductions to stories is that they
normally establish all of the key
players for the impending story as well
as Define the current situations or
goals of the cast we're following in
other words Luffy wants to be the pirate
king Goku wants to fight strong guys and
get stronger himself Naruto wants to
become Hokage and go wants to to find
his father for the most part these are
all easily understood goals for us to
get behind and moreover they hint
towards what the story will be about
later this is what EO versus Miata
offers this story to an extent and if my
saying to an extent sticks out to you
well it should because it's precisely
what threw me so off balance when
reading this story for the first time
and boy oh boy do I have my thoughts on
that the relationship and rivalry
established between Miata and IO in this
introduction takes place across two
bouts this initially half-hearted and
ill-prepared for spire and the sequel to
it which receives a lot more attention
buildup and preparation for all intents
and purposes Miata is the opposite of EO
in every way presently he comes from
boxing lineage he's trained his entire
life is naturally gifted in ways EO
isn't he's confident and as we soon come
to discover has an entirely different
style of fighting to the straightforward
pressure fighter EO naturally falls into
but does that
matter this is the moment EO shows us at
home and those in the gym he's trying to
gain the favor of what makes him so
special and no one is more surprised at
this level of tenacity Than The Prodigy
Miata Miata is forced to utilize his
speciality the counter punch to put IO
away the unobservant in the crowd see
this as a clear-cut victory for Miata
but the more Keen eyed understood the
truth Miata was indeed contending with a
newbie but that newbie possessed more
natural strength and grit that he was
comfortable with and while this show of
heart might have gone unnoticed by some
the head coach and owner of the gym took
notice he wants to give IO a chance and
a rematch with Miata once they both have
adequately
prepared EO versus Miata 2 2 all right
it's time for the rematch IO versus
Miata 2 and let me tell you this one is
better like way better and I say way
better because this was the fight where
everything Morty Caba was going for sort
of clicked with me in the story allow me
to
explain this is the first round of the
rematch Miata despite training in
Earnest these past few months for EO
despite having worked on on the sport
for years finds himself flat on his ass
following this stunningly depicted one
two combo from EO this pag just
fantastic you can see miata's shock and
everyone's surprise plastered across
their respective faces their reactions
take up as much real estate on this page
as a knockdown itself but when you turn
the page we discover that no one is more
shocked than EO himself look at that
expression it's a moment that speaks to
the culmination of the past 3 months
worth of perseverance and application of
hard work natural ability passion and
most importantly thoughtful strategy and
what's more is that this fight was
perfect but the strange thing to me was
I didn't understand why upon first
reading but now I understand what
happened in short I think this story
works best if you have no prior
knowledge of how boxing Works going in
because morala Ador the sport and
through this manga he will hold your
hand and guide you through everything
you need to know about it everything
from the rules of the sport to the
philosophies and approach all the way to
the multitude and minutia of details in
punching technique and counters to
specific Styles and all throughout this
introductory section like I did with all
the affirm menion shown in I've covered
in the past I was waiting for that
moment where EO and I would really
connect where I discovered my reason for
wanting to spend this time with this
character but that never really came
which I learned is exactly why EO is the
perfect character for this section of
the
story EO doesn't begin this story with
the goal of being the greatest boxer of
all time he doesn't need to stab himself
in the eye eat a devil fruit and
Endeavor to be the py king he doesn't
need to become Hokage or seek out any
other Fantastical accolades the popular
protagonists of shonan's Hall of Fame
have reached for instead through EO
being reserved by him being on the
surface unremarkable he aligned himself
with every kid that might read this
story one day and with a story being as
grounded in the fundamentals of boxing
as hajim noo is through that lens we can
appreciate what moric Kawa wants to do
with this story and it's not necessarily
entertain those like me who are fans of
boxing already because we already know
the rules we know what Shadow Boxing is
we already know why boxing is great
instead morawa wants to encourage a
young and eager generation to try out
this incredible sport for for themselves
and it's incredibly
[Music]
effective this moment is the culmination
of everything I've learned about this
story eo's character doesn't reveal
himself through dialogue really or
through the choices he makes necessarily
at least not in an impactful way just
yet instead his character is revealed
through moments where his training
boxing and proper technique all come
together in a stunningly perfect moment
on the page look at this page tell me IO
didn't just steal miata's soul with this
move look at his face he can't believe
it and this isn't your typical Shonen
strong boy eats a full-blown punch
because he's a Shonen strong boy nope
this is what happens in the real world
when you time your movement to receive a
punch at its weakest point it's an
incredibly clever move and this page
demonstrates just that through wonderful
momentto moment paneling as miata's eyes
slowly look up to see what he's just
opened himself up for we turn the page
and Wham this page gave me chills the
perfect setup to the prior page the
outstanding gestural drawings the
wonderful reaction shots and ample use
of white space to not crowd the panels
Mory Kawa knows what he's doing and I
hope it goes without saying but one of
the most important things for this
series to get right is the fighting and
various boxing matches and holy hell
does more Kawa knock it out of the park
in a fashion I've not yet seen put to
paper stylistically you can see a lot of
influence from the likes of Fist of the
Northstar and early JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure despite this however EO comes
with a distinct morava twist that
injects a lot of expressive stylized
humor and strong gestural drawings to
Grant the story its own sense of
identity to communicate the action and
effectively translate the true
techniques being implemented because
that's what it's there for to teach us
how boxing works where Dragon Ball can
get away with animators guessing how
martial arts stances and Strikes work
hajim noo depends on moric kawa's
extensive knowledge of not just human
anatomy and gestural drawing but the
specific technical inner workings of
boxing as so much of how this fight and
all the others that follow it function
is through his accurate application of
boxing's rules and
[Music]
practices this is the character defining
and series defining moment I was waiting
for and while it took a little longer to
arrive than I thought it would it
certainly arrived with a punch more
spectacular and exciting than I was
anticipating Miata versus EO 2 is
wonderful not just for those
aforementioned reasons but is important
for this story to function for in
addition to defining the series and its
lead character for us with Miata
deciding to leave in the wake of this
result we have our next goal Miata wants
their tiebreaker fight to be at the
finals of the upcoming Rook boxing
tournament at the moment EO only really
knows how to fight Miata it's what he's
specifically trained for and to get to
the rookie tournament EO will need to
obtain a pro boxing license and survive
a long series of qualifying and
preliminary rounds against some of
Japan's best prospects can he do it
let's find out license no EPO kicking
off this section and introducing us to
what the real world of professional
boxing has in store for the young EO we
get to witness the highly touted
greatness of takamura as he takes on the
third ranked Japanese middleweight kazoo
hirano the fight itself is great but
what it demonstrates is that what goes
into winning a boxing match isn't simply
the technique or natural abilities
applied in the ring during the allotted
rounds but instead the torturous weight
Cuts sleepless nights pressure and
workouts put in in the days weeks and
months leading up to a particular fight
I've only been reading the story for
about 2 weeks now and I'll be honest I
might be jumping the gun here but I feel
like this is a character takamura that
most don't love enough you might love
him but if you do I don't think you love
him enough at least not the way that I
do beyond what he means to EO as the
Catalyst which introduces boxing into
his life beyond his upbeat energetic and
engaging character with far more depth
than many the main cast there's a
subtlety to takamura that quickly became
my favorite part of this story takamura
wins his fight against the third ranked
middleweight with ease because well he's
takamura and that's what he does but
there won't be many opportunities for me
to talk about him during this video so
I'll say it here had it not been for
takamura I may not have kept reading the
story as I have the beginning of this
manga is very effective at capturing the
feeling of a gripping boxing match at
selling the sport to a younger audience
it offers a tone of appreciation to the
sport and all that good stuff but I
already had that going in what I needed
was a character to latch onto and while
there's plenty to find endearing about
EO I just never found anything too
relatable with him interestingly the
anime adaptation of the story seems to
have taken the initiative in changing or
adding things to the story and one of
the additions was to offer more time for
us as an audience to bond with oo as a
character near the beginning this is all
to say that I'm sure my experience with
the character of IO might have been
different had I decided to take the
anime on instead of the manga but as I
stood at this point in the story I liked
EO but I didn't love him and that became
increasingly the case as time passed on
in the story however through all of that
takamura was the exciting boy boisterous
entertaining and dubious character I
could see a lot of my younger self in
one that fit the more conventional mold
of a Shonen protagonist he's a brilliant
addition to the story and his greatest
contributions are yet to be seen so yeah
this is the physical application process
for the boxing
licenses this is mashi and he's a little
bit of a psychopath and with him morawa
establishes a pattern of exposition that
he'll make use of for the remainder of
this video each and every fighter that
will eventually stand in a prominent
position within a boxing ring will have
a unique style or trademark attack or
approach that allows us at home to learn
more about boxing through not only
showcasing unique techniques but also
showing how opponents plan to counter
and that's a built-in point of interest
in the sport of boxing you may have
heard people order the phrase Styles
make fights and that reflects the
approach morawa is taking here each
style demands something to counter it
effectively and depending on what style
the other fighter is comfortable with
opens us up to a host of different
approaches and possibilities a
particular fight can take with Miata he
was a counter puncher and with mashiba
it was the flicker jab and as IO easily
cruises through his license exam on the
horizon he has two fights fights he must
win to qualify for the upcoming rookie
tournament there's not much to them and
they really serve only one purpose each
so I'll keep it quick EO versus Oda with
this fight morawa establishes another
pattern that I have mixed feelings on
Oda is a 21-year-old fighter with an
okay record having started his career
with a promising punch he became lazy
and dependent on that one move we get to
see a lot of his backstory and
motivations coming into the fight as
well as the emotional struggle he
undergoes to truly get ready for this
fight against EO lest he lose everything
I suppose the fight itself could be a
cautionary tale for EO not to get
complacent or rely on and what worked
for him in the past and the match itself
is dramatic and forces EO to push
himself considerably all the while
teaching Oda the value of hard work in
the sport of boxing long story short EO
wins next fight EO versus Fuji EO versus
Fuji is even more simple than the prior
with the bullies from chapter 1 now
Having learned of eo's pro status in
boxing they start to develop a greater
respect for him and even go to see his
next fight fujiwara is eo's opponent and
he's effectively the thematic stand in
for the bullies watching on Fuji
implements a host of different dirty
tactics during the match trying to bully
EO 2 but the difference here between EO
in chapter 1 and EO now is that EO isn't
having any of it EO wins by knockout in
round one and through that gains a bunch
of new supporters in his former bullies
and with that IO is now qualified for
the rookie tournament where he may now
meet the 2-0 mashiba and where he hopes
to face his rival Miata in the finals of
the tournament currently Miata seems to
be the favorite his record now stands at
three wins to zero rookie tournament noo
this is the longest most complete and it
is the final stretch of the story I'll
be covering it's the East Japan rookie
tournament and in order to fulfill his
promise to rematch Miata in the finals
EO needs to win four separate matches
the first of which being round one Jason
ozuma versus EO generally speaking I
won't have too much to say on these
early contests they offer some great
matches to read through and I highly
encourage you to do so but this one in
particular though we're uh where do I
even begin uh you see Jason OA is
African-American and this manga was
written in
1989 maybe you see where I'm going with
this it's funny though the way you think
this could go wrong is actually the
exact opposite of how things actually
end up going OA is introduced and it
becomes clear very quickly that morawa
has a deep deep respect and adoration
for black boxers it's only natural given
how Central American boxing is to the
boxing world with famous fighters like
Mike Tyson and Sugar Ray Leonard making
headlines across the globe consistently
but the problem is that well I think
primarily as a product of its time that
reverence he has for them Loops back
around to being offensive again ozuma is
talked about as a natural fighter with
talk of his African-American Heritage
giving him a natural evolutionary
Advantage how fun and here I am waiting
through chapter or two of awkwardness of
1989 morawa waxing poetically about
biological advantages when all of a
sudden out of nowhere I am greeted by
literal blackface gag holy uh I
swear to God this reveal is a literal
jump scare at the end of chapter 28 it
is nuts but thankfully as I alluded to
earlier none of this extremely dated
depiction of race is in bad faith as
best I can tell it comes across as being
very dated but in a way that tries to
depict Jason in the most reverent light
possible rather than being based out of
any Prejudice that I can tell which is
good but still W literal black face H
all of that aside the character of Jason
OA might be the most righteous and
lovable in the series so far though we
do never see him again after this Jason
is a friendly kind and talented young
Soldier stationed in Japan that loves
boxing he's a natural talent and EO
finds his outward appearance
intimidating the anime naturally changes
this instead of his appearance being
intimidating it's his nationality as an
American that does it which makes more
sense as there's a larger boxing culture
in that country and of course they cut
ai's black face thank God yikes in this
bout we learn that Jason is fighting on
behalf of his community and family up
north in Japan that need help paying for
supplies it paints a sad situation and
becomes one of several fights in the
series where I felt as though I was
cheering for and related to eo's
opponents more than I did EO himself I'm
not sure if that was intentional or not
but that was my experience at any rate
Jason versus EO was a very competitive
fight with both sides going back and
forth applying pressure and skill
there's a moment at the beginning of the
fight after Jason scores a knockdown on
EO where the way morawa draws the panels
we are led to believe EO would fall
again thus TKO oing him out of the
tournament it's an exciting bout and
probably the most engaging fight the
series has seen thus far
the quarterfinals kobashi versus IO
there's significantly less to say about
this fight and it's really just another
bout where IO is faced with another
style of opponent to overcome in a
unique fashion kobashi isn't a technical
fighter or a power puncher but instead a
strategic one he studies his opponent's
style to create the perfect way to
neutralize their approach in order for
him to win on points and in a similar
fashion to many of the fights prior we
spend most of the lead of following
kobashi and watching Evo train however
there is is another element to the
training section of this fight that I
found interesting and compelling ever
since takamura last fought against the
ranked three middleweight he's been
chomping at the bit to get another fight
and during this buildup they finally
land him another gig and this time it's
the Japanese middleweight title the
largest honor takamura gym has seen in
over a decade however prior to this good
news you could see his frustration build
and build never wavering in the support
of EO of course but clearly frustrated
at his own situation with it acting as a
mechanism that teaches us about the
politics of the boxing world the real
boxing world the best don't necessarily
always fight the best instead Sometimes
the best avoid certain Fighters despite
their merits in order to hang on to
titles longer it's great that he finally
got another fight lined up but at the
same time I was aware that this was yet
another time morawa was demonstrating
amidst the list of easily obtained
fights EA was receiving he still whirls
away from where takamura is at
nevertheless the coach encourages EO to
follow takamura in preparation for
kobashi during his training camp within
which they discover a weakness in epo's
game one that he remedies right away
through targeted training and as a quick
aside prior to the quarter finals fight
with kobashi IO is interviewed within
school for some college thing and it
really made me focus on how I'm not sure
if I'm fond of EO as I should be he
doesn't really seem to have any obvious
flaws Beyond his own weakness which
would be okay but he always seems to be
pitted as of late against these
underdogs or sympathetic characters I
mean if we stop to think about it eo's a
naturally gifted power puncher has a mom
that supports his vocation entirely and
isn't struggling for money we never see
him do anything but work on his boxing
but in this interview we learned that
his grades are also good enough to get
into any college he wants and the only
running joke made at his expense is that
he has a massive schlong one of the
first things he learns about boxing was
that not every fight is glamorous that
the undercard fights are normally in
front of empty seats and this reflects
reality I love that morawa pointed this
out early on but yet no matter the lack
of notoriety his name brings or his
opponent brings all of his fights every
single time seem to be in front of what
appears to be a sold out crowd this
never happens compare that to the
audience of aoki's headline her fight
and the bleachers are totally empty it
all just seems a little lopsided and at
this point I was starting to feel a
clear favoritism for EO with every
passing chapter as if his time in boxing
is being glamorized to a point that
doesn't really reflect reality anymore
and that aspect of the story was what I
really respected about it early on in
the end EO through difficulty overcomes
kobashi for the win as characters go
kobashi was again another character I
found an emotional connection with as he
didn't really think he measured up to
anyone he fought his style was one born
from insecurity and a lack of confidence
in his own abilities the fight was great
and I think I was cheering for kobashi
all the more during
[Music]
it the Japanese middleweight title
takamura versus yajima this fight and
indeed The Fallout from it are what
cemented takamura as my favorite
character in this story and what more is
offered in addition to some wonderful
action a subtle and compelling story of
a man trying to live up to the ideals he
set for himself and other people despite
the toll it's taking on his body in the
story of hajim noo early on there's a
clear sentiment expressed by Mori Kawa
through the likes of io's coach and
owner of takamura's gym that he feels
Japan is falling off on the world stage
in terms of boxing unlike the United
States or other countries Japan has
never had a world champion and unlike
the' 60s 7s and 80s the future doesn't
look too promising as boxing has become
less popular in Japan takamura however
is the embodiment of the sort of change
and determination morawa wants to see
from his country a strong talented and
tenacious fighter that before he steps
into to fight the biggest match of his
life says that this Japanese title is
nothing but a simple stepping stone the
fight itself offers takamura more
troubled than he's ever seen before but
even then he summons from within deep
reserves of strength and bravery to
stand back up and unleash hell unto his
opponent to win the fight convincingly
in the first round this is all to say
within this story takamura is more than
just a man he's a symbol of what could
be in Japan the younger folks in the gym
all look up to him as well as those all
from around Japan but there is a crack
in his armor and honestly seeing it was
my favorite part of the 88 chapters I
read this week returning with EO from
the title win and his celebration
takamura is talking as normal when
suddenly as he starts to March up his
steps towards his apartment for the
first time we see him falter he stumbles
still affected by The Clash he just came
out on top of this is all to say that
well takamura builds himself as this
Titan and Eater of Worlds and While
others see him as a symbol of Hope for
Japan on the boxing World stage this
scene reminded us all of just how human
he truly is and like everyone alive
today he too has limits the semi-finals
hayami versus EO up until this point
while I have enjoyed the fights at face
value hajim no IO has taken a specific
and repeated approach to the fights and
opponents os's faced we find out who EO
is facing do some research on their
background Styles weaknesses Etc and
then get to work training up EO on how
to best counter them usually the odds
are stacked against him but through
sheer will and careful planning EO is
able to overcome the odds and beat his
opponents and the training that leads up
to that is certainly not something that
is handwaved away in fact the training
sections leading up to the fights is
some of the best material in these early
chapters in my opinion whether it be the
interesting training on the beach
leading up to the kobashi fight or any
of the other lead-ups to eo's previous
wins they all take their time to explore
a new facet of eo's boxing in a way that
is not only easy to understand but also
interesting and engaging however OS
fight against hayami offers us our first
real shakeup to this formula and
revealed to me personally many of the
strengths of this series as well as some
of its most apparent weaknesses the
established trend of learning deeply
about an upcoming opponent is fine but
as I read through this fight in
particular it became clear that it
created a bizarre dynamic between the
audience and EO that I felt may not have
served the story as well as it otherwise
could have an atmosphere where we at
home feel we understand both Fighters
better than they understand each other
of course the idea is that these tense
relations help Bond us to EO and create
an occasion for us to cheer for him but
I feel like learning these things
through preemptive dialogue scenes and
backstory delv serves that much worse
than through the alternative action not
the story term I mean real fist on fist
action and we see that so clearly with
takamura's previous bout we don't know
too much about the opponent going into
the fight and even further we are not
get given as much Insight on takamura's
internal turmoil leading up to the
occasion but as the two enter the ring
as well as afterwards the various Foos
in both opponents characters began to
naturally show themselves why because
fighting introduces one of the most
important elements in storytelling
pressure think back to something like
say I don't know Frieza in Dragon Ball
as we are introduced to him we get a
general sense of his personality and
demeanor through some of his actions and
interactions with others on Namek and
enough that we don't feel in the dark
about him as a character but that all
begins to greatly change as soon as
Frieza is pitted against Goku someone
who for the first time in this story is
able to apply pressure to Frieza that
very pressure naturally allows Toriyama
to bring out the true facets of frieza's
character his psychopathy his cruelty
his cowardice and unveil entirely new
depths to him by the end the majority of
what we know about his true character is
learned in the midst of his fight with
Goku and that is what makes fighting
such a great conduit for storytelling
its natural ability to squeeze
characters until something of worth pops
out and while hajim noo has utilized
some of this with other fights like
Miata early on or Fuji to a lesser
extent that is cheating in the grand
scheme of things it tends to put the
brunt of its character exploration in
preemptive Exposition rather than
pressure through action but again this
fight with hayami is different EO goes
into his training learning details about
Yami signature techniques and takes to
an incredibly rigorous amount of
training to prep for the bout but unlike
previous fights a surprising amount of
this training takes place off screen
when the fight night arrives EO arrives
too with a thoroughly bruised face a
product of that unseen training the
opponent he is facing this time is
without a doubt the toughest he has
faced so far with only a narrow chance
of Victory he has dedicated his entire
body and soul to training up on his
counter to hayami's Signature shotgun
style fighting and as the fight begins
and eo's training begins to pay off
everything changes haami The Prodigy
boxer known only for his famous shotgun
style takes it upon himself to switch
Styles completely to meet EO on his own
turf and Begins infighting the same
style EO uses this single decision
completely upends the established
structure of these fights so far EO has
only trained for one possible outcome
beating hayami shot Shing technique
through his developed counter but now
that is all out the window none of it is
in play anymore therefore EO is forced
to Freestyle his way through this fight
against a superior opponent and the
pressure is on in fact the pressure is
on for both Fighters now hayami is the
favored winner but he is now by his own
choice to show his own abilities off
fighting EO in his own stylistic
territory that is not an easy task no
matter how good you are and it doesn't
take take long before the pressure
builds to a head as EO finds himself
against the metaphorical ropes haami
goes in for a finishing uppercut
and oh my God EO Landed It wait it
didn't work this is what makes the
hayami fight Stand Out amongst all the
others to me it's got an added Dimension
to it the strategy EO has been toiling
away at perfecting has hit its mark and
dealt considerable damage but even that
wasn't enough to Grant EO his win for a
second time the rug has been pulled out
from beneath EO and all he has left is
to work out a path to Victory with his
skills alone that's awesome and it's
exactly the sort of stuff I wish I saw
more of from him furthermore the way
this fight has been depicted has been my
favorite there's a tremendous amount of
time dedicated to one round this entire
fight takes place with it five whole
chapters Chronicle these 3 minutes and
the drama contained therein creating a
real sense of tension as well as es and
flows you can feel the sudden rug pull
from beneath EO the tenacity it took to
claw his way back from that the effort
it takes for him to make the fight
competitive again and you can feel the
tide slowly shift in io's favor as
hayami slowly loses his rhythm and falls
behind him resulting in a fantastic
series of pages that show EO unloading
punches almost
unconsciously continuing to do so long
after hayami's face hits the canvas eo's
arms still pushing the air around him at
no point does hayami's inner dialogue
either ever suggest his spirit is broken
or that he was convinced he had lost it
all comes to a head with a fantastic
knockout following a single panel that
suggests hayami might once again regain
the apprehend it's a brilliant fight the
best one I've read in the series and
most importantly throughout the course
of the fight we learn an incredible
amount about the inner character of
hayami as well as IO through action the
RO unfiltered pressure of a good bout
allowed the characters to be organically
squeezed until something of substance
emerged never before while reading this
manga did I feel more naturally invested
in a fight and never before have I
eagerly awaited the return of a fighter
into the fry following a loss overall it
was tremendous fun and EO advances to
the finals where he waits for
Miata however in order for this dream
rematch to take place Miata needs to
uphold his end of the promise he needs
to overcome come an impressive and
increasingly unsettling mashiba who like
EO and Miata has steamrolled through his
opponents to the semi-final matchup
truth be told at this point in the story
I wasn't as keen on the idea of Miata
facing off against EO for a third time
in the final I wasn't entirely against
it mind you but given what we had
already seen from mashiba I was a little
curious what that sort of character
might offer EO in terms of dynamic in
the finals but I digress it's time for
the last semi-final matchup and it's a
doozy oh and also time for me to to
remind you that I recently relaunched my
patreon page to include a whole list of
actual perks and exclusive content we've
got behind the scenes outakes custom
made phone and desktop wallpapers of my
weekly thumbnail art early uploads of my
main videos without a single ad mind you
and we even have exclusive podcast
length q&as and that isn't even all of
it so if you like what I do and want to
support me or get any of those perks
check my patreon link in the description
the semi-finals Miata versus mashiba
something rather curious happens during
this fight that I quite literally could
never have predicted going into this
contest I was hoping for one thing and
by the time the final bell rang I wanted
the opposite which fittingly is what I
think moric kaawa wanted me to feel but
I worried that he may have taken things
a little too far but enough Vali the
first bell rings and immediately the
difference in skill is apparent Miata
lands at will demonstrating tremendous
speed and secures a decisive knockdown
early on mashiba who up until now has
had zero trouble with any of his
matchups similar to what I adored about
hayami versus IO where we got to enjoy
character revealing itself through
action this matchup takes it to the next
level going in we understand that
there's a little bit of bad blood
between the two fighters but only from a
passing Barb send from masiva towards
miata's father from there it's
established who the good and bad guy
boxers will be and how the matchup
expands on this during the fight is the
very best I've seen from the series
concerning this Dynamic while Miata is
taking the fight seriously he is not
driven specifically by the desire to win
the current fight but rather to fulfill
his promise to IO and reach the finals
for their fated rematch despite this
theoretical distraction mashiba appears
like a novice next to Miata who threw
Superior technique patience and
restraint when he needs to has mashiba
on the back foot or on his ass for
pockets of time we get to see snapshots
into the respective Fighters Minds
during this first round Miata staying
collected and focused on the fight to
come all the while masipa can't
emotionally contend with what is
happening right now willing himself to
stand up to Miata only for him to be
outclass with ease time and
[Music]
again this was such a fantastic moment
through action it demonstrates that
Miata was in total control all along can
exercise restraint and most importantly
wasn't willing to cheat and that part's
important the second round commences and
unwilling to accept the counsil of his
Corner mashiba rushes in hophazardly
hoping that infighting will get the
better of this exceptionally sharp and
game Miata spoiler alert it won't in a
wonderful moment of dramatic irony at
home we know that Miata won't be bested
by this sloppy approach because he
specifically prepared for an even better
infighter EO this is the first time I've
seen a challenged mashiba and what was
once the character I wanted to see
advance for the sake of Interest quickly
shifted to me rooting against him in
favor of the clearly much improved Miata
that is to say up until now mashiba has
demonstrated nothing of worse just
ignorance anger and cowardice in using
his Corner's advice pathetically
outmatched mashiba does the only thing
he
can he
cheats in another stunning move of
action revealing character mashiba does
the unthinkable compromising miata's
movement and scoring his first decisive
knockdown if my perview up until now had
been slowly shifting in favor of Miata
at this point I was frustrated beyond
belief by how helpless mashiba was and
couldn't Envision a world where I'd be
satisfied with him advancing to the
finals against IO and now with the wings
of Miata clipped for the remainder of
this fight he's faced with a bitter
decision at the end of round two throw
in the towel and fight another day or
risk his career by going into the lion's
den for round number
[Applause]
three to say that I was cheering for
Miata to somehow pull this out of the
bag would be an understatement Maybe his
leg wasn't that bad maybe he could find
a way to win if this fight had
demonstrated anything it was that if a
path to Victory existed Miata would find
it he's that good the entire final round
of this fight is orchestrated so
dramatically building to Miata summoning
up the deepest depths of his strength
and will to overcome the impossible much
like he had seen EO do time and time
again before now things really do seem
impossible for him as he lay knocked
down once again on the canvas energy
surging as he finds the will to stand
back back up but then he doesn't he is
unable to make the 10 count and mashiba
is declared the winner robbing miata's
rematch from him in the final right
under his nose in the end I don't know
how to feel about this fight entirely on
one hand morawa intentionally built up
Miata tremendously far beyond where he
had already sat the tragic Twist of eo's
fated rematch was wonderfully executed
and threw me for quite a loop both
story-wise as well as internally
furthermore he intentionally reinforced
my IBA as an even bigger villain than he
was before but through doing so perhaps
degraded his standing as a competent
fighter resulting in significantly less
interest from me in seeing him face off
against EO in the finals and you know
what that might sound confusing surely a
clear-cut villain is exactly what makes
some of the best final battles so
compelling in anime I mean I not too
long ago praise the astounding fight
that was Goku versus Frieza the ultimate
Evil and you're right under normal
circumstances that would be true and
while mashiba might be more of a villain
now he is one that proved to be a less
competent fighter going into this match
that required great fighting ability but
perhaps most crucially a villain can
only be as good as the hero he's pitted
against and as I pointed out earlier I'm
not particularly connected to EO but
that could still
change this was a genius move in my
opinion for the longest time my issue
with EO is that everything seemed to be
going his way that he doesn't ever
really encounter any issues unique to
him everyone has to prepare for tough
opponents in boxing everyone has their
own physical weaknesses but to me the
physical aspect of boxing while deep and
interesting it's the emotional or human
stories that emerge from this SP Sport
that make it as compelling as it
otherwise stands to be Rocky W earned
Sylvester Stallone and Oscar not because
he punched well but because it told a
story of a Broken Man learning to trust
himself and try his best despite the
odds in in Rocky 2 the line yo Adrien I
did it rang as emotional to us in our
ears because he achieved what he set out
to do he was able to try his best and
not allow his mindset or the occasion to
compromise his performance in the case
of this manga EO feels cheated out of
what he had been working towards all
along and on top of that in his
Whirlwind of emotions concerning miata's
loss and parting message of sorry this
is the most interested I've been in EO
personally unlike other instances where
he demonstrated lukewarm or milk toast
reactions this time alone with his
thoughts after seeing Miata stretched
out he punches a vending machine in
Anger smashing it before storming off it
was an anger directed at mashiba an
anger I've never seen from IO given that
I was less than excited at the thought
of someone like mashiba being built up
as the big bad to eo's uninteresting
hero type character I thought leveraging
this into a character revealing moment
for the young man is not only much
needed but clever I've been waiting for
a moment of weakness to to test eo's
emotions that will take him to the limit
of what he can make sense of and the
circumstances couldn't be more perfect
here a fight against someone that we as
an audience know he can defeat as long
as he doesn't let his Focus waver or let
his emotions get the better of him this
being more than just a physical fight
which we've seen EO overcome time and
again instead it's a fight with EO
himself to not get in his own way of
success to me that is a fantastic story
for someone as meek and frankly dull as
I find EO to currently be and we sort of
get just that immediately EO begins over
training something we have seen him do
sort of before but never to this extreme
degree leading to his hands getting
severely damaged in the process
resulting in him being unable to hit the
MS or heavy bag for half of his camp but
this is just one consequence and while
it has lasting effects on his training
over the next month to a degree I was
hoping for something more something that
would carry with him into the fight
itself against the increasingly
desperate mashiba a fighter we know that
can and likely will test io's patience
like no other in the story can and then
we met mashima's kind and sympathetic
younger sister that EO has a crush on
and then we see mashiba and his sister's
unfortunate backstory and once io's
hands are healed he's 100% focused and
totally dialed in to train and perform
to the best of his abilities during the
fight H the finals IO versus mashiba so
leading into this fight it seems like
morawa had the choice to work this
emotionally compromised angle with EO
and then saw an opportunity to weave his
sister into the mix and in the process
those two plot lines sort of end up
getting in the way of each other not
just by virtue of them having to share
half the runtime of this training
portion with each other but by actually
getting in the way of each other quite
literally IO is driven by Vengeance for
Miata but he learns about mashaba's past
through his friends and sister which
naturally puts IO into a weird situation
everyone around him is worried that this
Revelation with mashaba's sister io's
longtime Crush will diffuse the fire
that has been lit within him but in
quite the surprise even after hearing of
mashaba's personal life his relationship
with his sister all of it he still feels
largely the same he obviously feels
awkward about the sister but he plainly
states that none of the information
changes how he feels and is still deeply
driven to win both for his sake as well
as miata's the entire exchange is
honestly very muddy it's hard to tell
how we should really feel throughout all
of it but I think at the very least that
the turn of having EO not bothered by
masa's history at all is interesting
nevertheless on a brighter note there's
some really nice paneling leading up to
the first Bel seeing IO pensive in the
locker room the momentto moment paneling
helping to focus our attention on his
Focus stare across the ring at mashiba
it's all stunning EO is like a coil
spring ready to unleash the energy he's
been waiting to unleash this entire
training camp EO starts fast but can't
find his range past Mash's Reach This is
the story of the early minutes EO
manages to keep his cool and employ his
is weaving peekaboo style effectively to
get on the inside of mashiba but as he's
about to land his first punch the Bell
Rings apparently the judges score this
round 109 to mashiba which is hilarious
considering IO had virtually wait no
literally no offense for the entire
round he pressured him sure he tried to
hit him but he never landed he landed
nothing and mashiba seemed to land at
will for the majority of the round in my
humble opinion not being a boxer and not
being a boxing judge that is an easy 108
round for mashiba and I've seen it been
given for less but what do I know round
two begins and mashiba teases a means
with which he plans to dispose of eo's
right
straight the dude blocks with his elbow
now I've seen this block applied by the
likes of Canelo Alvarez and Mayweather
but never in a million years thought
that this approach would be taken in
this manga and I got to say that's
pretty cool eo's right hand is totally
compromised and with that my first issue
with the creative choices made rear its
head mashiba is the villain that's not
above Plain Dirty but this defensive
guard is a perfectly legal boxing block
and this is where I think the story of
the fight starts to get a little murky
following the Miata fight it felt as
though morawa wanted mashaba to be a
wellestablished villain one that pushes
EO to do things he shouldn't but then we
see his backstory and start to
sympathize with him at least a little
bit thus a leaving his villain status in
lie of something a bit more complicated
he'll do anything to win a fight
including block with his elbow which is
incredibly hard to do and through doing
so starts to bust up eo's right hand and
then out of nowhere through io's
perseverance in that same round he seems
to snap the ligaments in mashima's elbow
effectively reducing him to one arm at
that point EO can land at will the round
ends that I'm just sort of confused as
to how I'm supposed to feel who am I
supposed to be rooting for and why
emotional complexity is high
nevertheless however in the minute
between round two and three this fight
interjects one of the most interesting
question questions to the respective
Fighters eo's fist is broken and may
never recover fully if he keeps punching
with it in this round this is a
fascinating way to guide the fight this
is the manga's opportunity to tell a
story of doing the responsible thing
free of Revenge and ego to not allow
others to dictate to you who you are or
what your strengths are to do what's
best for you and your future and take
the loss but instead EO grits and bears
it risking his entire future on
something that is effectively a stepping
stone match Miata did something similar
in this boat against mashiba and morawa
is clearly trying to mirror that moment
in this fight but the difference I think
is that the story with miata's fight
called for that moment but with eo's
fight this creative Choice almost feels
at odds or antithetical to the greater
lesson of this matchup with mashiba in
the first
place okay so remember when I said that
I really appreciated how this manga took
a sport and didn't do Supernatural
things with the people participating
outside the Realms of possibility I
praise this for trying to tell a
realistic boxing story well mashiba
without the ligaments in his elbow used
his normal guard with the elbow bent
through sheer willpower and
determination to not let his kid Sister
down he performed a physiological
Miracle which I suppose is appropriate
to offset the incredibly dangerous and
not at all worth an Endeavor EO is
trying to do now I really don't know
what to make of this normally this would
be fine but the way mashima's arm was
demonstrated to be was as if he had no
ability to lift it at all like he lacked
control over it as if it were a limp
limb mashiba ends up Landing the flicker
jab with his compromised left Limb and
lands a massive right stray to knock
down IO throwing caution for his future
into the wind IO makes the 10 count and
lands three massive right hooks to the
body of mashiba but again the psycho
persists I think at this point we've
left the Realms of reality it the way
eo's punches have been built up mashi
should have every rib in his body broken
as well as a ruptured liver and kidneys
given his lack of Defense it seems to me
Unthinkable to take that many clean
shots to the body and not have the match
called off or let alone not go down once
and this I think would be permissible in
any other story but hajim noo has been
great for staying within the Realms of
realism and so the problem that arises
therefore from this sudden shift in
presentation is that now I have no clue
how to gauge this fight's progress so
much time had been spent on establishing
this Sport and how it worked in the real
world but now we're veering into
Supernatural territory and thus has
removed the realistic foundations and
expectations we've
built but I don't know how much that
matters because that shot was awesome EO
lands a massive uppercut lifting mashiba
off the floor again not very realistic
but there you go and he's still standing
there EO lands another straight right
and finally he goes down I got to say
however despite my criticisms one aspect
that has never let me down has been Mory
kawa's paneling the way this entire
section is demonstrated the way to
offset the complexity of each individual
pose that he struck EO wins and it's in
fantastic fashion the postf fight
reactions from mashiba and IO are my
favorite part of the fight they're given
wonderful drawings and tremendous
Revelations of their individual
characters but in the end EO won and boy
does he win everything he wins WIS the
fight he has zero lasting consequences
it seems from the rash actions he took
in the third round he wins the
tournament wins this year's most
excellent boxer award which I didn't
even know was a thing he could win up
until the panel was presented to him in
I was almost half expecting mashi bision
to push him out of the way and run onto
the platform to embrace EO and saido I'm
yours please kiss me or something like
that honestly it's almost comical how
great everything ends up going for this
character the first chapter painted a
very different picture but since then
it's been nothing but W's for this guy
outside of the obvious conflicts he's
had physically with Fighters the closest
thing IO has gotten to actual compelling
character to find in Conflict was the
anger he displayed following miata's
loss and he overcame that super easily
in the end the very first creative
element in this story that caught my eye
was the ring bell morawa illustrates at
the beginning of the first chapter and
as it happens it's something he
illustrates at different points in the
ser series perhaps at the beginning of
each volume and I liked this creative
choice because I thought it was a cute
metaphor for what was to come you see a
boxing match is divided into rounds
which begin and conclude at the sound of
the bell ring one of the things I love
about boxing is that it can be looked at
philosophically as a metaphor for life
as soon as that Bell Rings you don't
know what might come your way you might
be in control one moment and the next
you're on the back foot you might be
cruising and the next you're struggling
for the next gasp of air the Rocky films
communicate this philosophy well by
describing Life as a boxing match that
you have to keep picking yourself back
up and move forward that much like a
ring bell whether you're ready or not
life doesn't stop for anyone and no one
is going to hit you harder than life can
so when I saw that the first chapter
began with a ringing Bell it reassured
me perhaps naively that this story was
going to be about more than just boxing
that it was going to be about life and
the struggles one needs to fight through
in order to come out on top take any
substantial a boxing Centric film from
the last 40 years as an example Raging
Bull Rocky Creed million dooll baby the
fighter Cinderella Man all of these
films use boxing as the Fantastic
metaphor for life that it is and through
it tells some of the best and most
captivating human stories and I think
perhaps going in with that mindset set
me up for disappointment I should have
gone in with no expectations but this
isn't to say that I didn't enjoy my time
reading Haj noo I had a ton of fun in
fact deciphering what Mor kawa's
approach was fascinating and seeing the
world through his eyes was captivating
if nothing else while I didn't fall in
love with the main character it's hard
not to fall in love with the clear
passion morawa has for this sport the
man even opened his own boxing gym in
Tokyo for God's sake so what I can say
that hajim noo was the once in a
generation type story that I was hoping
for it was at the end of the day
everything that it needed to be a
perfect vehicle to encourage those young
and old alike to take up the beautiful
sport that Mory C loves so much and in
that same vein I want to point each and
every one of you out there who liked
this story to stick with it and follow
along with K manga koda's release of it
in English we need support official
releases as English speakers I don't
want to stand for anything less I read
up until the end of the tournament but
there's even more released for you all
to enjoy and check out right now and hey
let them know that I sent you I would
love for there to be a time where
YouTubers and actual license holders in
Japan can work work together and
actually promote these things to our
audiences so please go to the
description and check out and support
the official release you won't be
disappointed